reports from belarus say that a
prominent opposition leader has been
abducted by
unidentified people in the capital minsk
the website toot dot b-i-b-y
excuse me says that maria koliniskova
was pushed into a minivan by men in
black
clothing and driven away she's seen here
at a massive protest rally held on
sunday
more than 600 people were arrested in
the demonstration
protesters have turned out for the past
four weeks
calling on long-time authoritarian
leader alexander lukashenko to step down
after a contested election
ntw correspondent nick connolly joins us
now from minsk uh
nick tell us witnesses say that maria
kolesnikova was
bundled into a van what do people in
minsk think has happened
not using official police in uniforms
with
some kind of identification to do these
kind of things we saw it happen
yesterday at the protest where people
were being arrested by
police in plain clothes carrying batons
some with flak jackets
without any kind of id on them in terms
of media calisthenic over yes
she was out in the city walking
apparently going to a post office to get
some documentation
for a legal case that she has running
against so when she suddenly disappeared
an eyewitness saw a van an unmarked van
without any number plates which just
said
telecoms on it and men without a uniform
bundling her into that bus no one has
been able to reach her for the last few
hours
this does seem like significant
development she was the last of the
three women
who were campaigning against alexander
lukashenko in that very
um very prominent and very successful
campaign this summer
the other two have left the country she
had refused to do so and now it seems
like the authorities
have decided to take her out of this
protest movement okay so nick sorry
apologies
due to some technical difficulties we
missed your first sentence of that first
answer so you can
perhaps just fill us in on on what
people think
about what happened but but also tell us
about the role
that kolesnikova has been playing in the
protests so far
well there seems to be little doubt on
the part at least of the opposition
supporters here means that she has been
detained by the government will be
by people in plain clothes by security
agents not wearing official police id or
uniforms
um the police hat or the interior
ministry rather has denied
any involvement in this arrest that's
not convincing many people here
maria kalistenkova was or is someone who
is one of the prominent faces of these
protests someone who is part of the
trio of women campaigning against
alexander lukashenko along with smith
tikanovska and vereni catsepcarla both
of those now abroad she had refused to
leave the country
and is now facing the consequences of
that she has also recently
been involved in setting up a party i
think that's a bit early now
for now this this protest against
alexander luxembourg regime
is taking place on the streets and not
through traditional politics but she is
certainly
one of the faces of these protests and
her arrest will be a significant blow to
the opposition
so what happens now for the opposition
movement
nick because i mean sunday saw more huge
protests now we have this reported
abduction yet president lukashenko is
holding firm
well he's definitely refusing any kind
of dialogue he seems to think that any
kind of negotiations would be a sign of
weakness
he has referred to protesters as rats
his government has defamed them as
prostitutes and drug addicts
so really hard line here and no seeming
willingness to kind of engage with these
people
on the other hand though kalista's
arrest though symbolically a blow
i don't think in practical terms will be
too much of a problem for these
protesters
because lots of this is happening on a
kind of horizontal
level people organizing themselves
without any kind of orders from above
you see it in universities you see it
even in kind of residential compounds
where people
are reaching out to their neighbors and
organizing
some kind of sit-ins or hanging up flags
other kind of symbolic challenges to the
regime so this is definitely
a sign the government is making good on
its promise to clamp down but i don't
think it will stop people coming out in
ever bigger numbers as we've seen in
recent weeks
mcconnelly on this developing story for
us in minsk nick thanks for your
reporting